dans le ciel de kiev les deux nations se
multiplient
les soldats ukrainien tente de résister
face à l'avancée inexorable de la russie
pour le président volodymyr zelensky
moscou a lancé la dernière phase de son
assaut
cette nuit l'ennemi va utiliser toutes
les forces dont il dispose pour briser
notre défense où sa manière méchante
jury non humaine cette nuit ils vont
tenter de s'emparer de siège
dans un message publié sur facebook
l'armée de terre ukrainienne a indiqué
avoir repoussé une attaque nocturne sur
l'avenue de la victoire l'une des
principales artères de kiev les
autorités incitent les habitants à se
défendre le ministère de l'intérieur a
ainsi largement diffusé ses instructions
pour fabriquer des cocktails molotov les
soldats ukrainiens eux son second départ
les habitants à qui des armes ont été
distribuées
on nous a donné des armes au bureau
d'enregistrement militaire on nous a
donné des armes en tant que volontaire
militaire c'est juste que maintenant la
situation est telle qu'il n'y a pas le
temps d'attendre une convocation
les autorités ukrainiennes dénombre déjà
plus de 130 morts face à la guerre les
ukrainiens tentent de se protéger en
dehors des abris ils se réunissent dans
des stations de métro ou encore dans cet
hôtel de kiev selon l'onu les combats
ont déjà fait plus de cent mille
déplacés en ukraine près de la moitié
ont déjà eu deux pays